parents should care about crt this is a
tribe live story glenn younkin recently
was elected virginia is governor partly
because he promised to ban teaching of
crtcrt stands for critical race theory
which argues that every american
institution upholds white supremacy
journalists uh asura nuamani
uh reveals some rather creepy crt
lessons that are taught in schools the
money filed freedom of information act
request that for schools district to
reveal how they pay consultants to
spread crt we found 300 plus contracts
they know me
every day i'm getting a new contract
some conservatives want to ban the
teaching of crt that's not a good idea
government shouldn't be banning ideas of
taking choices away from teachers bands
shield students from important topics a
better solution is legalizing school
choice
let parents take our tax money to a
school we choose can you unpack that
well start with the end
being if there's a market everything is
made better by competition
and you look at new york where i'm from
and you used to work they spend more
than twenty thousand dollars per kid
if you do the math that's four hundred
thousand dollars per classroom okay
how many good teachers could you hire
for that
you had to be able to hire
four good teachers and this was not
capital cost this was just
what they put in to teach the kids every
year
so where does the money go
nobody can find out it goes it's not
just the union it's the the
administration all that the bureaucracy
and the ptas get caught up the people
who like going into windowless
conference rooms and trying to figure
out how to run other people's lives
unless there's competition that forces
them to make some cut somewhere and just
spend more on the right things that the
parents want
it'll never get better
i don't think the critical race theory
stuff is a giant threat but
they have books like woke baby i mean
critical
theory is a law school theory
but it got down to the teachers and many
of them believe racism is everywhere
which i think is nonsense
there's more inner marriage than ever
before and isn't that a measure of
racist getting along if you
are eager to marry someone of a
different race
but some kids are being
taught that they are if you're white
you're a horrible person and you stole
from non-white people you did it well
your parents did it and passed it down
to you but you have this huge advantage
and that's evil
do you do you believe uh
in the power of affirmations
i'm not sure what it means power of
affirmations like saying hey yeah uh you
know
i'm gonna have a good day today you know
be careful what you joke about what be
sarcastic about because the spirit stops
having faith and the words that comes
out of your mouth i'm meant to do
something special with my life you know
do you believe in affirmations do you
believe in affirmations daniel i do do
you believe in power of positive
thinking
sure can we say we all agree that
nobody's saying an affirmation every
morning okay i know you do right norman
vincent peale the power of positive
thinking new york preach you know pastor
all this stuff right so i'm i'm giving a
talk and
i'm speaking in front of a group of kids
and parents probably a thousand people
in norman i'm up there talking about how
great this country is right america is
the greatest country in the world like
you know american exceptionalism this is
the greatest place and next thing you
know i see a couple of the teachers go
like this
and i'm like okay my job is to read body
language this is what you do when you're
speaking from stage i'm like okay
curious i want to really talk to these
guys afterwards so i don't even need to
go to them they come up to me
uh listen uh first of all thank you for
coming up but can i give you some
feedback yes you have to be very careful
telling young kids a lie like america's
the greatest country in the world do you
realize america is one of the most
racist
countries in the world and she went off
right all these things about how
horrible america is
i said let me ask you a question she
said yes i said do you believe in
affirmations you said uh what's after me
and i told her i said
do you think it serves kids
to think positive thoughts about
themselves about their families about
their heritage about their country
uh
i think that's a formal manipulation oh
really that's a formal manipulation
interesting so i shouldn't tell my kids
son
you can do almost everything you put
your mind to except some things that
have physical abilities if you can't
jump 46 inches you're probably not going
to be lebron james outside of some of
physical stuff you can probably do
anything you want to do right is that a
bad thing to tell a kid
no no but that's not the point we have
to tell people the truth about the fact
that racism exists i'm like ma'am
i just came and spoke at a white school
and i'm from iran
like do you realize how you invited me
and i spoke and i said how great your
country is this is an example of how
great america is well no you haven't
seen all the other stuff i haven't seen
all the other stuff i was in the
military went to kentucky have you lived
in south carolina or kentucky i lived in
south carolina and i went to a waffle
house which i don't miss going to waffle
house right so i go to waffle house this
guy's looking at me
saying uh where are you from
i said what do you mean
he said can i just be honest i said yeah
sure i've never seen a note like that in
my life before i said this is a
legendary armenian nose you cannot make
these types of things you have to have
genetics the guy actually said that to
your face i said you realize your pretty
boy knows that you got it cost me 9 000
to make it look like yours i said you
need billions to make yours look like
money okay all the money in the world is
not because he starts laughing we start
laughing i'm from iran he said you're
from iran i ran i said yeah from iran he
said what are you doing here
you know and we're at this waffle house
i said can i whisper too so it's not i
don't want people to know about it
because i'm in the uniform i said listen
just between us i'm a spy here i'm
trying to spy and study all your
military tactics cause i'm gonna take it
back to iran it's it's why i'm here
seriously no man i'm kidding with you
he's running for his gun right
yeah so so to me the biggest thing that
crt doesn't get is affirmations work and
if you want to put negative affirmations
they also work if you tell
hundreds of thousands of kids they're
racist by the time they're 18 they're
convinced they're racist and it
continues for decades and decades and
they consume and i think that's a
problem i think it's a different
approach we can take i may be wrong
there's people fighting their way into
this country give me a break
yeah people want to come here but
when the kids are older
it's right to teach them about some of
the horrible things that america has
done
and
it was
just not taught to any kid when i was in
eighth grade
i i mean i think we all went
to school and we learned about the civil
war in slavery i don't think
it wasn't called critical race theory
but we were all very well aware that
that was like a word of the that was
part of exactly when the white people
civilized america and
rescued
people from the savages that stuff was
in
my courses mm-hmm what was that
i'm vastly older than you guys what was
that wrong
is that incorrect no
america
did some racist
nasty no no but your statement is that
white people civilized
he's asking is that wrong because
lincoln i think lincoln's not black
right is he white or black at last i
checked he's still awake yeah he was a
white guy
he's not with us anymore by the way adam
the
enlightenment the other
western values civilize the world
correct
and you're not allowed to say that
anymore but it's just true
i i don't know uh maybe glendale high
school focused on it but i remember i
grew up i grew up now i'm not gonna lie
to you when i was in high school i
didn't like white people when i was in
high school because what was sold to me
was
white people take advantage of everybody
else that's what was sold to me when i
when my teacher was white when she's
teaching history
what they did to blacks what they did to
ray
you know till today you're not going to
find an office of mine or anything of
mine without an mlk picture on the wall
till today mlk is a hero too too and
obviously he just had a celebration so i
don't know if the history's
unless if it's inaccurate and lincoln
didn't play a big role then we have to
talk about it
i mean i grew up learning that you know
the horrors that we inflicted upon
native native americans yeah when we
landed here i mean
took all that i mean they've got like
1.2 percent of their land left but i
mean these are
these are things that i learned growing
up in school
but i think we're missing a major point
here when you say we did this we did
this we're all immigrants my family came
over from russia in the early 1900s okay
his family came from iran i don't know
you're jewish you know your family
probably landed on ellis island your
family is in town island 19 i don't know
i mean unless you're like original o.g
jamestown waspi english from 1600's
we all immigrated from some countries
where we had to get the hell out of
because we were getting persecuted
whether that was religiously or or
economically economically and we had to
make a move so when we white people
how many people are just straight white
people that just landed on plymouth rock
you know like the old uh malcolm x i
didn't land on plymouth rock when the
rock landed on me
so the the old white people thing i just
think is it just a blanket statement
that just actually doesn't hold water to
most people am i wrong on that john
stossel
no
and also
slavery was ended by white people most
college students now think
america created slavery started it now
you're contradicting yourself john
i like to do that
you do so why are you teasing him
keeping pbd on his team keep going keep
going it was the british
more than we but even people from mexico
who ended slavery but it
began in the middle east
it was perpetuated all over africa
and somehow
white people are the bad guys and it
continues to this day in various parts
right
six countries let's not forget that we
killed gaddafi and now there's a giant
slave trade in libya let's not forget
about that
that's your point with that it's at his
point slave trading is still on today
there are thousands of slaves being
traded in libya
after we
bombed and assassinated gaddafi
so we shouldn't have killed gaddafi are
you advocating for us not to have killed
gaddafi the voice of god called david
you may have a good point i don't think
we should have killed gaddafi tell us
why because we brought the country into
chaos gaddafi had backed off he under he
understood that that we had his number
he had backed off he wasn't
the terrorist he was
10 years ago before we assassinated and
and look what happened after he was gone
the country has fallen
into complete chaos and it's often
justified by this idea of american
exceptionalism we go into all these
other countries and tell them how to run
things and we make it worse i mean an
even worse example than gaddafi is
what's happened in iraq we we prop up
these qadhafi's these hussein saddam
husseins as these boogeymen we these are
horrible people we got to get them out
and next thing you know that it creates
this vacuum boom isis boom slave trades
in libya so it's like what are we
trading one you know
uh
what is he just the complete uh leader
uh totalitarian is the word i'm looking
for we're basically a complete
psychopath mindset that ice will bring
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]